so listen I got a bunch of questions for
you
um as I always do
um if someone is actually you've done
such incredible work over so many years
if someone is actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why
uh I would probably pick something
because I am eclectic but my roots are
are dramatic uh independently spirited
drama I would probably pick something
from that because that's my first love
so I would probably go with uh pig or
Joe or uh uh bringing out the dead so I
listen I love Face-Off I mean I love
Face-Off and I know that there's been
talk for a while Adam Wingard but maybe
doing a sequel is that actually gonna
happen is that something that interests
you oh yeah I know I love face off too
and I think Face-Off is a sequel that
lends itself to a lot of uh twists and
turns and unpredictability it's it's
almost like uh if you factor in the idea
of
Offspring and and Castor and Sean having
children and these children grow up then
it becomes like three-dimensional chess
and what's then it's not just the two
John Travolta and myself it's four of us
ping-ponging and going at different
levels and it becomes even more complex
I think there's a lot of
fertile ground there
um I had maybe one meeting uh in an
office but I haven't heard anything
since so I don't know I really if Adam
is directing I really want it to happen
uh me too he's great and I I think we
should share similar tastes we have
similar sensibilities I liked everything
he did with Godzilla and Kong and I I
think that he's smart you know he has
respect for cinnamon and various kinds
of iconography so I think it would be
great uh jumping into why I get to talk
to you with the old way
um so you [ __ ] most of the movie you are
with your daughter played by Ryan and I
think my favorite scene in the film is
um you teaching her to cry and I wanted
to know as I was watching it because I I
loved the scene so much
um was that all scripted how much was
found in the moment
no that was that was all in the script
and we can credit Brett Donahoe for that
I thought it was a terrific scene too in
fact that was one of the scenes that
made me decide to jump in and make the
movie outside of being my first Western
and wanting to put that hat on after 45
years but of doing this but
um you know
to me at the heart of this story is a
family drama my favorite genre is family
drama yes it's framed in the location
and the period and the clothing of the
traditional Western but at the heart of
it it's a story of a father and a
daughter who are both social Misfits who
are both uh trying to act like they
belong in society trying to act like
they can feel and cry trying to act like
they can laugh at somebody's jokes but
they they really don't have that I don't
know what the condition is it's never
explained in the movie and there is they
both have a propensity towards violence
but the idea that this family of Colton
and Brooke go through a tragedy go on
the road together and learn to love is
that was compelling to me and that scene
in particular that you cited
that to me was
yes it's sad but at the same time it's
hilarious because Ryan is so good in
that scene when she's going trying to
intentionally she had to intentionally
act bad to act like she's a great actor
who's trying to act like she can't act
to fit into society and I thought it was
it had a lot of a lot of heart to be
honest with you I laughed a lot watching
it I like out loud laughing well so was
I and I almost they had to cut around my
laughter she knew I was cracking up
because I liked her fake crying so much
she's so talented Ryan I mean she really
is for her age the depth the complexity
the maturity that she has in film
performance is quite something to behold
I think we're going to be seeing a lot
of her I hope so had you actually been
offered westerns prior to this and just
said I don't want to do it or it's
because it's a genre that is anyway let
me just stop with that I don't recall
any westerns being offered to me any I I
don't recall it at all I I really don't
I don't know
I I think I would have looked at any
Western very seriously I to me it seemed
like an easy match people laugh when I
say grew up in California I live in
Nevada but my point being it wouldn't be
such a leap like as if someone was
inviting me to portray medieval England
that I could understand people may
wonder you know but in this case it was
like well this area I understand that I
feel like I speak with a bit of a Mojave
drawl you know I mean I just it seemed
like an easy match to me and I am
mystified that it took this long to
happen but I'm glad it did so the first
trailer for renfeld came out this
morning and I could not be more excited
it looks pardon my language [ __ ]
awesome
um and I I love your look in it and uh
Robert told me that it was your idea to
wear all the Rings
um uh in the film and I'm just curious
could you talk a little bit about coming
up with the look of of Dracula well I
had a lot of help there were there were
a ton of super talented people on that
movie that you know helped design the
the look
um
you know we wanted it to be more
homage more Christopher Lee I favored
Christopher Lee as Dracula and I liked
his kind of 60s hairdo and
um
but the the Wardrobe the costume and no
I didn't come up with the idea for the
rings that all came out of a wardrobe
they came in with all that maybe maybe
they sent something in me that I would I
would like that but I that was really on
that was their their contribution what
is it like because you've done so many
roles through your career what is it
like getting the phone call hey we're
making a movie and we want you to play
Dracula right well first of all I don't
know how you say no to Dracula but but
two things come to mind one it's a it's
a character he's a character that's been
done well many times and didn't been
done poorly many times so
you want to be on the side of doing
something well and also you want to be
on the side of doing something fresh and
something that pops you know and to me
because the movie's really not about me
I don't I don't of Dracula rather I
don't have a lot of screen time it's
really Nick Holtz movie and it's about
Renfield I didn't have the time like the
near the two-hour narrative to really
dig deep into Dracula's pathos per se
it's not that but I did have enough
screen time to be able to try to develop
a pop art style to the character that
hopefully will be a nice contribution to
the other performers that have done it
that have had their take on on this
legendary character in in both
literature and Cinema and that note I
need to stop sir I always want to thank
you so much for giving me your time and
I wish you nothing but the best oh thank
you so much take care have a great day